cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us for more on this vaccine
breakthrough
doctor the news crossed just after 9 00
p.m
last night what's your reaction and
what's next
uh i mean this is it right i mean
finally there is light at the end of the
tunnel
we're going to go on offense against
this virus and that is
exciting science is coming through here
that being said the task of vaccinating
300 plus
million people in the united states is a
daunting one and especially
this vaccine has to be stored at minus
94 degrees fahrenheit so it's being
distributed across the country now
and there are going to be programs in
every state each state has its own
requirement for who will be vaccinated
first
but it's beginning alex azar the
secretary of
health and human services says that the
vaccine could be available as early as
monday or tuesday that's the good news
but with health care workers surely on
the front lines of those who will be
getting
this vaccine who's next in line and how
quickly before
regular folk are in in that number
so health care workers will get it over
the next many weeks remember the first
shipment of several million doses is a
fraction of what's needed for healthcare
workers and people in long-term care
facilities
next you're going to people with medical
issues so these are people who are
higher risk for complications
for being hospitalized because as of now
we all know that around the country icus
are filling up or
full in many places so we have to
protect people
who would be hospitalized and then we'll
go to the
rest of the country so really over the
next six months we're going to vaccinate
everybody
it's going to take time and as everyone
keeps eluding wear that mask
by time so we don't can we can stop
spread the virus and we can win this war
we've heard recently about potential
side effects maybe for people that have
severe
allergies and then there have been
questions about ages and and who can get
this vaccine how young is it 16 or 18
give us some sense of any restrictions
or warnings we may see
early on initially it's 16 and over
it hasn't really been tested in young
children and that's ongoing now
and rightfully so they test later to
make sure it's safe first than adults
there were two cases and healthcare
workers have a a
reaction an allergic reaction to the
vaccine which is not uncommon and has
been seen in almost every vaccine
if you have a history of allergies or
have epi pens so that you know you know
it's a severe one you probably shouldn't
get it
in the beginning and then there are the
pregnant women
or nursing women both of them it hasn't
been tested in
major issue in that the majority of
healthcare frontline workers
are women and some of them can be
pregnant either knowingly or unknowingly
and so that's an issue we're paying
close attention to
we're paying close attention to it all
dr angus
and thank you for being our like
telescope
thank you